hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and kippy just want to thank you for
tuning in to ru garbage
yeah guys make sure you subscribe that
way you get the episode as they come out
you can also go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and hd
streaming
do it yeah welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy
individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan
and h foley
baby here we go hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast this is
are you garbage the show where we sit
down with your favorite comedians and
fun if they grew up classy
or if they're complete trash i'm your
host stage foley coming at you on a
glorious day here
gas digital studios in the big studio in
the [ __ ] heart of the east village
new york city alive and well baby
my co-host coming at you from right
[ __ ] next to me
give it up for everybody's best pal mr
kevin james
orion hey what's up everybody thanks so
much for tuning in
uh we appreciate it as always please
make sure you go rate review subscribe
on itunes
also full video available on youtube you
can subscribe there as well
and if you want to get uh the catalog of
our previous episodes you can get the
you know the live chat and everything go
to gas digitalnetwork.com use promo code
ayg
we get to wet our beaks a little [ __ ]
bit if you know what i mean a couple of
bucks in the big man's pocket
keep me in hawaiian shirts so go do that
we appreciate all the support so far
guys yes sir we love all you guys very
much and we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly
and i mean incredibly special guest here
with us today
via gas digital 6g technology
satellite elon musk we got him on the
line ladies and gentlemen
this gentleman isn't a very successful
sports analyst actor producer
commentator
and of course mixed martial artist as an
actor he has appeared in warrior magnum
pi
triple threat macgyver den of thieves
triple x
and strike back and of course as a
professional fighter
he is the former ufc middleweight champ
he was inducted into the ufc hall of
fame july 5th
2019 he's 6-1 a buck 85
fresh out of the shower i've met him for
about five seconds i'm [ __ ] petrified
of this guy
his pro record he's got 30 wins 17 of
those wins by night night
this guy puts people to [ __ ] sleep
all right he's fighting out of
manchester england ladies and gentlemen
he is the host of believe you me
right here on the gas digital network
give it the [ __ ] up for the champ
mr michael bisping everybody
well that is quite the intro that is
quite the [ __ ] intro but thank you
very much
it's quite the career i tried my best to
be in a good mood see the thing was
i've just had a knee replacement and i
had a guy here doing physical therapy
for the last
90 minutes and i was like can we speed
this up can we get the show on the
[ __ ] road
and i went straight from that which was
[ __ ]
painful and then straight into this and
then i was trying to you know the
technical difficulties trying to get
the camera going there's no need to be
scared no need to be terrified
yeah right i want a pair of sunglasses
and a fake beard so you don't know who i
am
a couple of things off the top i have
not seen 185 pounds
in forever now i am
definitely a heavyweight and for the
wrong reasons i've got a heavyweight
belly that's for sure and i can tell you
again right off the top there's no need
for this podcast because i'm definitely
garbage
that's what that's what the producers
we've been getting some [ __ ] sneak
peeks of your behavior and the producers
say
all garbage yeah yeah well
nothing new there i feel like there
should be a jet ski parked right next to
you
here's a further example i'm texting my
wife that i need my coffee so i am a
male chauvinistic
garbage old school i like it well you
look fantastic that's a sweet haircut
man he's got the [ __ ] baby blues you
look like a goddamn avenger
yeah i don't know what you're rocking
underneath that car
with any kind of [ __ ] hairstyle is an
improvement on yours so
thank you very much but still i haven't
exactly got much competition
on this show yeah i'm hanging on for
dear life the rogaine
ain't working and the big man wears a
hat well you know just for the record i
don't know if they told you this but i
did a little wrestling in high school
so uh we're kind of like compatriots
right there oh yeah we've got so much in
common i mean you look at me
you can't tell the difference between us
identical
i like i like i like bisping i was
looking at uh i was like doing some
research
uh obviously you know who you were a big
fan but uh you're the kind of guy you
you're you've gotten better you've aged
very well especially
since you got some money you got the
nice hair you got the good clothes he's
like really put it together in the
[ __ ]
in this in the second half of this i
know you say you're garbage but i'm
looking at that office i see a lot of
deep mahogany wood
i see fine leather chairs i don't know
man yeah
it took me a while i've done the believe
you me podcast with luis for about i
don't know
four or five years now and then i
thought i should actually try and
[ __ ] put some effort into this as a
possibility
from the webcam so you know it looks
good i bought a piece of furniture
no big deal you know we've all done it
on occasion here and there
yeah but you're going raymond flanagan
i'm going [ __ ] rent a center
it's a classy operation you got yeah no
i i just stepped away from my podcast
one day and i looked at it and i thought
what the [ __ ] is this this rinky dink
[ __ ] okay
i gotta step my game up a little bit i
don't know what's happening now because
ever since i've come onto vmix it's
thrown
all of my camera angles out of whack
i've been [ __ ] around with it for the
last hour but this is the best i can get
it right now it looks great
well thank you sir i appreciate it so
what are we doing here got the [ __ ]
belt behind you it looks good
well we want to get into a little are
you garbage but first i'd like to know
uh what's the origin story like where
did you grow up
how did you grow up brothers and sisters
the whole nine yards i know you were a
military kid right
yeah yeah sorry let me know the one you
made back i just need the coffee you
made
sorry i can't speak to you guys you've
got
laser attention i'm on your buddy but
i've moved out before we love the bike
i went to the kitchen to [ __ ] i said
i'll do it from there and i brought my
coffee with me and now i'm back here
with you [ __ ]
i just need my coffee i'm good i'm gonna
get through this i need my coffee all
right
origin story born in cyprus 1979 which
was a british army base
my dad was a sniper in the army i moved
to england
moved to england when i was i don't know
two years old something like that
prior to me being born my great great
great thank you darling appreciate it
baby
my great great great grandfather
whatever he was a um
an elite soldier shall we say and
he uh played a role in in a battle
and because of that role he was awarded
with uh the title of account
the count and a ton of land anyway so
throughout the middle ages my family
were living in mansions and things like
that there's a book about it called
the history of the bisping family and
then the second world war occurred
and overnight the border moved so my
family went to sleep
in polish territory and then overnight
the border moved they woke up in
uh german uh territory and then it will
land up against the wall
shot dead my granddad and one or two
others were the only ones to make it out
alive
he came to england he had me and uh i
was raised pissed [ __ ] poor
broke on what we call a councillors day
which is what you call the ghetto
so thank you [ __ ] germany
[Laughter]
yeah they got a big drag record these
houses in the book they're [ __ ]
they're like buckingham palace they're
massive they're insane
and as i say don't get me wrong i
wouldn't change a thing mom and dad but
uh yeah it would have been better had
world war ii not happen
that's a that's an already garbage first
to have like you were like [ __ ]
royalty your family you come from like
you come from good stock
real good [ __ ] stock real good stock
but as i say you know what i mean uh
yeah it didn't help me out
at a bad time yeah yeah no no had i been
born one generation earlier well saying
that if it had been born one generation
earlier
i might have been one of those shot
against the wall so i'll take this
version
there you go yeah yeah what was the
battle that your great-grandfather was
in do you remember the name of it
no no i'd have to read the book but i
don't give a [ __ ] that much you know
what i mean
your other question was brothers and
sisters yeah this is i come from a
family of eight
so the six siblings damn i was the
middle child
yeah there you go and what did your dad
do why you while you were when you were
growing up
was he was he in the military even when
you guys moved to england
yeah he well well he was yeah he was in
the military and then um
as i said he was a sniper but then he
was caught in a couple of bomb blasts
so he got medical discharge early and
then you know
you you come to find out there's not
much call for
ex-snipers
[Laughter]
in the day-to-day world so the poor guy
you know you kind of went through a
shitty time you know to me struggling to
find work
right no tsd and things like that you
know so
uh you know it happens all the time you
see and hear about it all the time so
it's not a special story but yeah my dad
kind of got thrown on the shitty
after giving his life to the army that's
a [ __ ] great story right there and
you would say
without a doubt that that's uh you know
added to your drive
being a fighter when you were coming up
in the ufc correct having those humble
beginnings
yeah absolutely i mean listen my mum and
dad always did everything they could
you know what i mean we never went
hungry or anything like that we weren't
[ __ ] poor poor boy but
you know we just oh we just didn't have
the designer [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying it was working
you know my mum and dad did everything
they could so i've got no complaints
never went hungry but you know also it's
nice to have the finer things in life
so that was definitely my drive you know
just like because i've done every
dead-end job
under the sun you know and i remember
working 60 70 hours a week
but still being [ __ ] pissed poor
still being [ __ ] broke still not
being able to afford decent [ __ ]
driving an absolute piece of crap
borrowing [ __ ] a few bucks off my mum
just to put gas in the car to get to
work i'm like
what the [ __ ] is this there's got to be
more to life than this
so uh so yeah that's kind of why i
started fighting
what was your first job when you were
growing up
i left school at 16 um i remember
everyone was going to college and [ __ ]
like that and i'm like you crazy i can
get a job for 120 pounds a week
i love it that's i love that mentality
garbage mentality you [ __ ] say
i'm gonna go start making some cash and
then in a year you're like this ain't
like this ain't good money
i'm like 120 pounds a week do you know
how [ __ ] up
i can get 120 pounds
that's all i cared about at that time
i'd given up martial arts all i wanted
to go out do was go out
get drunk get in a fight and talk to
some chicks and 120 pounds a week
[ __ ] allow me to do that
that's the best life for a 16 year old
going to get [ __ ] up going to the bar
and hitting on chicks dude come on
i'd say the worst one and you'll like
this one i guess the worst job i had and
again
i went through a succession of dead-end
jobs i worked everywhere in my hometown
where someone like me could work and i
guess the one
everyone's doing a stint here and i
didn't do it for long but i worked at
the slaughterhouse
killing cows oh [ __ ] yeah killing cows
well i i wasn't doing punching them in
the head
[Laughter]
when i when i initially started that
they had me squeegee mopping blood
into drains right and then like
when you first walk into a
slaughterhouse it's as you can imagine
it's
it's terrifying i remember my first job
there was people they were doing the
sheep
when the sheep go up in single file and
as they go up close you know
like a clamp holds the head and the guys
are just chatting away and they just
they just slice the head of the the
sheep and top it into a bin behind them
but they don't really look where the bin
is because they're so used to
just do that and then they do the next
sheep on and on and on
and uh my first job of the day when i
first got there i walked in
i'm seeing this i'm like what the [ __ ]
is this
i try to go wrong in college they're
like michael do me a favor just go
pick up those uh the heads that missed
please and put them in i'm like what the
[ __ ] so i get a shovel
and i'm like with the shovel like trying
to pick them up
and i'm taking my time obviously after a
while the super bowl
supervisor walks off he's like what the
[ __ ] are you doing man pick them up
they're not going to [ __ ] bite you
so that went on for a bit and then i
said um
i said to him i said look listen i said
to the supervisor one day at break i
said come on i said i can do
something better than this you know
squeeze him up and blood into a drain i
can be more used to you
he said let me think about it anyway i
went and had my break i came back
he goes you're right mike you know you
you're you've you've got a lot of
potential he says
i'm gonna make you an apprentice
slaughterman i was like whoa
that's not really what i wanted to do
best job in the building mike you're
gonna be an attempted slaughterman
and uh yeah so 500 cows a day we
slaughtered
and it was very very disturbing but i
didn't do it for very long
god damn the vp of throat slitting
that's
[ __ ] crazy
it was nasty man it was nasty and all
those vegans out there probably losing
their [ __ ]
i don't think digital has any vegan
listeners
yeah how do you think a [ __ ]
cheeseburger gets on the plate buddy
it's not pretty let me tell you holy
[ __ ]
and now you live out in uh you're out in
california right that's where that's
where the home base is now
yeah that's right yeah so obviously uh
you know i had a successful career in
the ufc
and having the career in the ufc
uh having the role in the ufc i got a
work visa and i come from a tiny small
town in
england called clithero no opportunity
there lovely place don't get me wrong
lovely people very very nice weather
[ __ ] sucks
rains nearly every single day cold wet
miserable
nothing to do about 10 15 000 people but
about 30 pubs so you know where the
priority lies
so a great night out but but uh yeah
there's
there's no ambition there so uh i had
the work visa
for america and i said well [ __ ] it
let's give this a shot
so my wife's australia we were going to
move to australia initially
and then um the training situation
wasn't that good
but i know in orange county there's you
know there's it's a hotbed of talent
for mixed martial arts for ufc so i said
[ __ ] it let's go there
and we talked about it for a while and
i'm pretty sure all my friends and
family thought we were just bluffing and
talking [ __ ]
and i said to my wife one day i said
listen let's just do it let's just do it
and she goes well i'll do it i said well
[ __ ] it let's book the flights right now
so we booked the flights right then and
there for the week after
she's like what are you doing that's
crazy i said well listen if we don't
like it
flights go both ways yeah you know
wherever
[ __ ] it you only live once so that's
what we did and we've been here ever
since
jesus christ did you when you when you
moved out there did you have any money
yet or were you like
still going out there struggling yeah no
no no
i was you know i was uh financially
stable okay
so i had money in the bank and i was
comfortable things were going well so
of course you know that that's what give
you gives you options unfortunately
yeah yeah yeah well i was poking around
on instagram your house now is pretty
[ __ ] pretty
dude you got a [ __ ] nice setup out
there that pool is [ __ ] something
else
but what we're curious about is why we
wanted to focus on your life now
um is how much of the you know the
garbage
past has seeped into your life now like
i was asking you about the jet skis and
all that kind of stuff we're going to
get into it
but we just want to see how it all
breaks down so we're going to play a
little game
called are you garbage kevin and i are
going to ask you a series of questions
answer the questions open and honestly
uh and anything that it stimulates as
far as a story or whatever please
feel free to share just so you know
you're talking to two
uh blue-collar irish pieces of trash
from uh the suburbs of philadelphia so
you're in good company
yeah i hate to say it to you but i had
you [ __ ] pegged them on you didn't
think we were two aristocrats over here
mike
you guys you look like a couple of
[ __ ] successful stock brokers what's
going on
i don't like it buy low sell high
so high buy low that's my advice
oh no of course of course all right so
you're out there
um obviously you live in a single-family
home you guys got a nice place out there
from the
from the looks of it it's pretty classy
yeah it's a nice place you know we uh
it's too big we don't need this place
it's
[ __ ] big that is a five love to be
able to well i know that sounds like
it's a
[ __ ] thing to say
you like my house it had a pool i come
from england nobody has a plan
nobody has a pool and we got well excuse
me
can you swim kids yeah you know
a little bit you know that's real trashy
when you got the pool but you can't swim
that's [ __ ] great
i can swim but when i do swim i make a
lot of noise
water flies everywhere but i don't
necessarily move
much you know what i mean but when we
got here one of the
requisites was whatever house we find we
have to have a pool because we've got
three kids
sure took them away from the took them
away from the family you know what i'm
saying as long as we have a pool
they'll think it's [ __ ] amazing yeah
and uh it'll be a nice distraction
unfortunately it works
that's great dude that's a pool that's
that's something that's new money you
got a new money pool that's all
it's got the rocks the [ __ ] rock
waterfall [ __ ] looks
real classy and let's ask you this
it just came as it is nothing to do with
me you know what i mean that's the way
it was
[ __ ] it let's go i love it so
i want i want to know this off the top a
big thing on the show is we talk about
our people that have uh
garages and have outdoor refrigerators
do you have a setup out
out back on the patio where you have a
fridge that's just for like beers and
sodas and all that stuff
yeah yeah i had that uh all uh kind of
taken
care of a few years ago i had like a
nice barbecue area put in
so i got the beer pump i got the i got
the uh the fridge
okay you got the keg outside but the keg
got it all yeah of course what kind of
round there what kind of beer you got in
the keg this is a big one what do you
got
yeah i'm like a uh a stellar artwash
you know peyronie but lately i
lately i'm loving the sapporo that's my
thing at the moment yeah
that's nice crisp what's
what's the fixtures in the kitchen what
do you got a sub z fridge
viking range what are we talking about
here you'd have to ask my wife
that means it's great yeah he doesn't
even know
i don't [ __ ] know we've got a smaller
[Laughter]
stainless steel it's stainless steel
uh i don't know and then yeah you know
all the
usual bits and bobs you might find in a
kitchen
we have a microwave this guy's got money
over here ufc money's got the microwave
going
i've got a 50 microwave from target
who does the shopping over there do you
ever go to the grocery store
or is it all your wife takes care of
everything no no no
well yeah i mean she's a great housewife
you know she uh she
devoted her life to my children and i so
we're very lucky in that regard
she does most of it i help out on
occasion you know now and again if the
mood takes me
if i'm particularly bored if it [ __ ]
lock down
really get it to me let's go down to
ralph's
yeah that's where you shop you shop at
ralph's
yeah yeah yeah the rouse is the closest
one to us right there can you imagine
bumping into him at the grocery store
you're [ __ ] getting lying in front of
him by accident yeah he's
just picking up [ __ ] cheerios see
bisping yeah i get that all the time
people are like michael bisping
[Laughter]
that's why i'm here yeah i'm not picking
up [ __ ] pasta
and orange juice if i was on baby
yeah not going out of town to get the
staples um all right i got one this is
uh this is one that's been very popular
the past couple of weeks it's very
divisive too
do uh do you brush your teeth in the
shower
no what kind of psycho thank you thank
you
you're a [ __ ] lunatic well well
number one let's break it down
you keep the toothpaste by the sink yeah
you have your toothpaste and whatever
garbage you know and then you go turn
the shower on
right you give that a few minutes warms
up you don't grab the three present
toothbrush
what's wrong with you he's crazy i doubt
okay i'm saying this from a poor
person's perspective i doubt that you
can reach your sink
from your shower what do you got the big
waterfall a couple of sprays
all right oh no i see where you're going
with this one certainly you guys are in
new york as well i get it yeah no
unfortunately we're spoiled we got a big
massive bathroom yeah so i couldn't
reach
if however i was in like a confined
bathroom and it was tiny mm-hmm
and i could reach my uh toothpaste
i think i would no come on it's
disgusting
no i don't know i'm all about
convenience i'm all about speeding
things up and getting it doing it in a
timely fashion so
but there you go you're not saving that
much money because we're saving that
much time because when you're brushing
your teeth you're not also washing your
hair you're standing there brushing your
teeth
so whether you're in the shower out of
the shower it's the same
yeah but still it's a collective effort
this is the cleaning zone
we're in the shower we're doing the
teeth we're letting the water
run the soap and jump you out of your
hair while you're doing the brush that's
disgusting
you step out you're good to [ __ ] go
that's right
that's what i'm [ __ ] talking about
the champ knows what's up this guy
look at this guy's [ __ ] gleaming
everywhere you can tell that that's the
man
that shades these [ __ ]
[Music]
you're never gonna convince me otherwise
that's trash i got another hot button
one that's big here growing up
uh back in england or now how do you
feel about having milk with dinner
did you ever when you were growing milk
yeah
i mean i was kind of raised on cereal to
be honest so
uh i'm talking a glass of milk
yeah you're asking me now yeah we sit
down at dinner at the bisping's house
you're having spaghetti
would you would the you or the kids have
a glass of milk
i mean my son my youngest he might have
a glass of milk because he likes a glass
of milk and if he wants a glass of milk
he may have a glass of milk
sure but he's a child i mean if i'm
having a bowl of pasta i'd rather have a
glass of red wine but you know what yeah
because you're a classy [ __ ] guy if
you want a glass of milk whatever floats
your boat but i'm not a [ __ ] 12 year
old
do you what's the what's the wine
situation over at the bisping house you
have a wine cellar
no no no no don't have a wine cellar and
we we
go through a lot of wine but we don't
drink expensive wine gotcha
what do you drop on a bottle of wine
you're like going you say you're going
to dinner someone's house
you stopped to get a bottle of wine what
are you dropping on uh it's
that's that's a tricky one but we don't
really we i don't know if we're
unpopular but
we haven't
[Laughter]
i am aware of this phenomenon and when
you do that it is a tricky one because
you want to make it look
like you know you got a decent bottle
yeah i'm not finding 50 bugs
you know what i mean because they never
they never look at it
and go oh oh and then try and go oh my
this is a great
wine no whenever you do that at
someone's house they grab it and they
just
put it to one side simple as that and
it's forgotten about yeah
mix but they're definitely at home
they're looking at them yeah we always
drink
iron if you know the brand 19 crimes
yeah it's got the mug shot of those
[ __ ] old guys
yeah yeah yeah it's good 10 50 about 15
maybe it's [ __ ] good though it's nice
it's delicious you ever put uh you ever
put ice in your wine
no i don't but i do i do like it kind of
chilled
the red wine sure that's a very that's a
very classy thing a lot of people are
chilling their red wines these days
this guy's [ __ ] classy i feel it
coming
i'm a classy [ __ ] man
it's hard to argue with him he's got the
[ __ ] belt he's got the hall of fame
thing behind him he's got his
he's got his flag behind he look this is
like [ __ ] this is like espn worthy
class right now what kind of product do
you put in your hair what are you using
in the hair you got a forming cream
no no would you well okay you just hit
the [ __ ] nail on the head because
i i i used to go and see this girl and
get my hair cut and she'd have all these
[ __ ] gels
right and if i don't put anything in my
hair it it it has a life of his own it
spazzes out it goes all over the place
excuse me and then just the other day
because if i don't put if i don't put
gel in it
it goes crazy and i look insane right
but i don't want to look
like a [ __ ] slick my herb out on a
tuesday
somebody knocks on the door and you look
like you're going to [ __ ] dinner do
you know
you know what i'm saying
so i said to my wife i said there must
be [ __ ] something i can put in here
to stop it spazzing out and freezing out
and sticking up in the air
and she came with like a foam yeah so
you hit the nail on the head some kind
of foam
expensive looks good looks good how
often do you get your hair cut
cvs expensive it's like three four bucks
come on
come on hawaii no not three four people
spending money you're spending way more
than four bucks
come on dude that's not prell
unfortunately with the hair cutting i
know you're gonna talk [ __ ] on this one
but i i
commentate on tv sure you know so i
gotta stay tight
every three weeks or so now when you
when you go to an event to commentate
well they do it for you like in hair
they'll clean you will they clean you up
in hair and makeup or no
nah nah and as of right now there is no
hair and makeup whatsoever so
we're gonna take care of everything but
yeah no there's never never been a hair
person never never makeup and wardrobe
and all that but
yeah the hair gonna take care of it
myself
it's a tough world that reminds me on a
side note i saw a video you showing up
to fight island screaming at everybody
at the valet which [ __ ] solidified
you in my heart as uh
one of my favorite people he's he's out
in the middle of the hotel
what the [ __ ] going on all right
let me give you a quick bit of backstory
on that you're right it has been seen a
lot of times and i'm
arriving fire and i'm screaming i'm like
who's in charge here
let's let's just [ __ ] go through it
quickly though i've done a 15-hour
flight no i've flown to vegas
we've been quarantined in vegas for
three days then we fly in a hotel room
in a [ __ ] hotel
then we fly to abu dhabi right it's a
long
ass flight it takes us forever to get
through costumes then we get outside we
get hurted
onto a coach we sit on the coast no [ __ ]
and we don't move
for three hours right i'm like what the
[ __ ] is going on then we drive
a mile down the street and then get off
at the hotel
could have walked there a billion times
and it's so hot and so humid
and there's all these [ __ ] people
there and they're taking pictures and
they're filming everything
and i see all the shoes never listen
i see the suitcases and i say out loud
oh there's my suitcase at least i know
my suitcase made it
and they all get lined up and then
eventually when i get off the bus
my suitcase isn't there right it's gone
it disappeared i'm like i [ __ ] saw it
a minute ago
i know it was here and i'm asking them
all started off i
started off very politely so excuse me
i'm looking for a camouflage
samsonite suitcase no response nothing
excuse me
it's getting nothing nobody nobody would
answer me
and by this point
who is in charge here
gonna be in charge well someone just
[ __ ] answered me but of course
they don't show that they just show me
losing grace yeah
of course no i i i i was it was a
kindred spear because i lose it i lose
it i gotta temper i lose it i'm
traveling for sure dude
it's so easy to lose let me ask you this
that flight to abu dhabi you fly private
no come on what do you take me for what
the [ __ ] you think that would be like
three bills
what about first class business class
ah okay still pretty classy was the last
time you flew coach
the last time i flew coach would have
been the time i paid for the flight
that's [ __ ] garbage that's garbage
yeah just flying nice on other people's
buck
anytime you pay for the flight yeah
we're going to economy [ __ ] back of
the plane right by the engine
yeah um well when you this with
flying is a is a travel's a pretty big
issue would you will you take your shoes
off on the flight
yeah why wouldn't you i don't know some
people are against it
that's trash i [ __ ] love this guy
you have to take your shoes off why
because you got 40 000 feet in the
[ __ ] air
guess what happens everything swells it
gets tight you've got to let them
breathe
that's right especially if you're
boozing your feet swell up real [ __ ]
bad i don't i don't take my shoes off
and then stick my feet up in the air and
put them in the person next to me
and generally in business class you've
got your own like little booth
you've got a full flat bed you know you
can get pajamas on and lie in bed so i
don't know about you
last time my pajamas on i also have my
shoes off
i know that sounds very large i'm not
paying for these flights
it is what it is i like it i like it um
let's move into the bedroom a little bit
i'm curious about
when you sleep when you sleep how many
pillows
do you have and what positions one
pillow one you're one
pillow pillow guy yeah
i mean how many pillows do you need oh
minimum
guy i do one under my head tucked under
i do one in between my legs and then i
hug one on the side
so three pillows yeah i i have the
shittiest
tiniest most like gives no pillow
ability i don't know
cushioning yeah function what however
i yeah because i have i have a few that
when i sit up in bed watching tv i'm
propped up
but then it's time to go sleep they'll
get thrown on the floor and i keep the
little shitty one
that's all weird that's like old like
poor person [ __ ] like i don't deserve
this yeah yeah it's old school you gotta
tough it out
no no it's just what makes me that's
what's comfortable
when you were growing up did you have
your own room or did you bunk up with
one of your brothers
yeah so there was like uh we had a four
bedroom house six kids
mom and dad and then two in each room
damn
see that's where that comes from that's
what a single pillow comes from
yeah yeah i see a [ __ ] kicked out of my
elder
[Laughter]
ah good stuff all right what do you got
kip let's see
um you mentioned it earlier what's the
grill situation at the house you gotta
get you got a propane you got
charcoal do you do the grilling is it
build in
oh yeah not for sure i definitely do the
grilling if anyone [ __ ] comes near my
grill then i'm coming out of retirement
uh my my father-in-law graham
they're the best guy in fact my wife's
family they're [ __ ] amazing and
graham's the best guy he's the most laid
back
kind generous awesome funny loves a
beard just a good [ __ ] dude
but he's a barbecue [ __ ] control
freak
right and we play this weird uh
passive aggressive game right and
whoever has the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] things yeah he's in control
whoever the tongue is in control
and clicking them is a power move when
you click that and i don't let them out
my hand but then i need to piss and i'm
like i can't take the tongues to the
bathroom
[Laughter]
down and then i come back and he's in
control
on that [ __ ] and we're both
doing this thing and you know because
he's great but then he throws all the
meat on there he doesn't season it
he throws all the meats on at the same
time
i'm like the chicken doesn't cook at the
same speed as the steak
the sausages need to go on later yadda
yadda yadda you know but he just
throws it all on no seasoning i'm the
[ __ ] that's paying for the meat by the
way
[Laughter]
that's garbage like you cocksuck i pay
for that steak [ __ ] tomahawk steaks
25 a pound
exactly and you're burning the
[ __ ] oh man how do you take your
steak
medium medium all right gentlemen
very classy i used to play medium rare
but it's a little yeah and you know i
mean
just drop the [ __ ] axe i like it
medium i used to say medium rare
medium rare please yeah [ __ ] that
i i used to say medium rare plus because
i heard that once in a fancy restaurant
medium rare plus is what i what is what
i want so i sound like an [ __ ] in
restaurant
excuse me do you do a medium wear plus
and then sometimes some of the
restaurants have
had the audacity to say no
no we don't and then that gets my back
up and i'm like well
i'm paying 45 [ __ ] dollars for a
steak i'll have it cooked exactly how i
[ __ ] want it yeah
you tell that chef to do it medium rare
[Laughter]
and then just bang it on for a minute 30
seconds apart whatever just plus the dog
oh that was my favorite [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] funny are you a fast food guy at
all
no really i mean i do like it i do love
it i used to eat
a lot of it but uh these days that i've
got older me and my wife we
we we try and eat pretty healthy you
know but
it depends i've got days when i'm
[ __ ] very healthy and then i've got
days where i just say
[ __ ] this i don't know me both brother
you and me both
he's got more of a couple of [ __ ]
days i don't know if you can see the
bottom half yeah
yeah i'm not sure but uh hey listen come
on i love a good [ __ ] cheeseburger
and fries as much as the next man
well how do you feel about the filet of
fish at mcdonald's are you a fan
i i don't eat mcdonald's unless unless i
i'm at an airport and i get a [ __ ] uh
what is it the
sausage and egg mcmuffin that's a
[ __ ] gentleman's
meal
come on [ __ ] mcdonald's is garbage
it's bad it's hard man it's bad and the
fillet of fish get [ __ ] thank you
thank you mike now we're fighting i'll
tell you that right now
uh all right speaking of we're in
restaurants and food a little bit um
have you ever left a bad yelp review
no i haven't in my entire life and i
want to know who these people are there
okay listen if you leave
a bad well a bad yelp review i can kind
of get
you know what i mean you went somewhere
it was [ __ ] and you want to exact some
kind of revenge
you want to take it out fair enough but
who the [ __ ] goes somewhere and leaves a
good one
if i hold on and have a great time i'm
not leaving a good one
you know my good reviewing you got paid
and you got a good tip i'm not
then going out of my way and going dear
yelp
today i went to an amazing restaurant
the food was cooked the way it should
be expected to be medium rare please
yeah yeah no you give me a medium rare
you're getting a bad rope
no just like people that leave i'm not
disrespecting these people
you know comments on youtube
and then the [ __ ] that leave
negative on negative comments on social
media you know
yeah they [ __ ] that's a difference
that's a different kind of trash
i've never left the [ __ ] negative
comment in my life i've said
thousands of negatives sure look at it
every morning god
[ __ ] me here we go babe this
dickhead's at it again look at this one
look at him posing in chairs you don't
even look good
but um but yeah i wouldn't go on there
and type it out
i know it's that's that's next that's
next level [ __ ] uh
loser [ __ ] for sure hey gang we know
everybody's going through a tough time
right now
but i tell you what we here at ru
garbage we've got
the cure and of course we're talking
about dickatyourdoor.com
use it it's absolutely fantastic i mean
let's face it
everyone's bummed out right now things
aren't going well so why not send a
loved one
or more importantly send one of your
enemies
a delicious chocolate dick i mean who
knows
this might be the one thing that keeps
your grandma alive you might not haven't
seen one in a little while she takes a
piece of this thing
take a little peek keeps you going for
another six months nana
dick at your door dot com makes 100
handcrafted chocolate
in the shape of dicks that's right baby
dicks
you can send them anonymously or grow
some balls and put your name on it like
a gentleman
yeah you know what i mean let them know
what's up they also make prank greeting
cards that make
[ __ ] noises when you open them
so check out dickierdoor.com and if you
use the code garbage that's
g-a-r-b-a-g-e
garbage you'll save 15 percent on
possibly
the most delicious chocolate dick you'll
ever have in your mouth
baby unfortunately we can't say the same
for nana
i still love you grandma don't worry
about it baby once again gang that's
ticketyourdoor.com and use promo code
garbage
to save fifteen percent now let's get
back to the show
um all right what do you got big man i
got this uh i'm curious about what kind
of sh what kind of things drive you
crazy as far as like when you see other
people do them that
you think is trashy and something i saw
the other day
i guess i want to get both of your
opinions on it is uh
uh we were we were out to dinner and we
were sitting down and we were eating
and uh the people next to us had gotten
something wrapped up to go
and then at some point right they opened
up the conduct to con
to go container and started eating the
leftovers
out of the ca to go container at the
table
and i almost [ __ ] threw up so they
stuck around and started getting a
little bit packaged and thought
you know yeah let's look around a little
bit package i can ask my wife what's
something that i think
other people do that is trash it down
babe take a listen
hey come in slide a chair off this is
the beautiful rebecca baseball i don't
know the names of these people
hey what's up rebecca hey mrs bisping
how are you
good how are you hey what kind of show
refrigerator do you have
uh you mean the brand yeah
samsung and then we wanted to know what
was it
the range what's the oven
that is bosch very nice
that's german [ __ ] they're good at
engineering that's nice
does michael not know this no no he
doesn't oh he didn't know anything
no because i need i need to ask you some
things you know so
slide over but um yeah slide off a bit
because you
made me keep me comfortable but uh what
was the question so i mean
uh somewhere something that people do
that
i think is trashy garbage it drives you
crazy you know
something that other people do yeah yeah
but i'll tell you this right now i'll
tell you this come on
i'll tell you this right now um american
drivers
this is probably off topic
i live in orange county the people out
here they're very nice they're very
polite
you know if i speak my normal tone of
voice they're like whoa
why are you being so aggressive and
things like that
is he an aggressive driver
no but he does not appreciate it when
people honk at him
or sure any kind of disapproval he just
loses it could you imagine him getting
out of there
it's so embarrassing no no no no
you know so these people are here
they're so nice and they stick to the
rules
like [ __ ] crazy you know what i mean
like they see my dog
off the leash the [ __ ] here now say if
you like your buddy [ __ ] off
mind your own business i'm not in the
open
i'm on the top of a mountain there's no
one around i'm letting him have some
exercise
that type of people they're very [ __ ]
anal but they don't use their blinkers
so they'll be in a [ __ ] machine right
traveling 90 miles an hour
right don't use we call them indicators
you call them blinkers because they
[ __ ] blink
well we're indicating
yeah yeah but you don't use them you
don't use that and then when i do put an
indicator on
you [ __ ] speed up to to to
minimize the gap so we can't get him
then
play a dangerous maneuver in a giant car
that's going to kill somebody
so anyway if you're one of those
[ __ ] out there that doesn't use your
blinker
[Laughter]
what's the what's the snack situation in
the house what kind of snacks do the
kids have what kind of snacks does
michael get
do they get like what are lunchables
doritos
what's going on well michael's um he
likes sweet snacks whereas what myself i
like
savory snacks so michael likes a lot of
chocolate and a lot of cookies a lot of
ice cream
what's this michael what's your cookie
brand
no i don't yeah i don't really have me
yeah no no the
the wife of my daughter
i like fruits and not cadbury cadburys
listen no no disrespect to uh
that's a british yeah but yeah chocolate
sucks the chocolate situation out here
is
bad yeah the chocolate chocolate in the
u.s is tough european chocolate is
the only the only good chocolate you can
buy here is european chocolate
it's a [ __ ] import chip yeah cadbury
i'm a big fan fruit nuts uh
a hundred percent big caramelo guy i
love the cadbury caramel
yeah yeah that's good that's good yeah
no i i do have a sweet tooth
granted but uh but there's there's
always snacks and [ __ ] in the house when
i was competing as a fighter
i might have to lose 30 pounds
throughout training camp
you know i'd say [ __ ] stop with the
snacks and the chocolate please because
if i see them
have to eat them you know what i mean
and then but
i i i get the craving so much i go to
like bed where's the chocolate because
we haven't gotten there i'm like [ __ ]
off
i know we have chocolate we're not
having it i'm like babe i just want a
piece okay
where is it and she goes okay and she
goes to the cupboard she goes here
there you go don't give me [ __ ] and then
i'll eat it and then the craving
what are you doing why'd you give me the
chocolate why did you
why did you do that is there anything in
the house that's just for dad
that the kids aren't allowed to have
that's just for michael
fruit and not yeah the kids can't like
that really
and the vodka
i'm trying to think what else i'm sure
there's some other things that
particular ice cream that you oh yeah oh
what's the brand yeah what's the brand
why the brand the ice cream brand
it's it's one that i just buy from
ralph's i think it's from the private
collection
spending that ufc money on the private
collection i like it
see these guys are classy man yeah
you're not trash
it's the season caramel truffle oh
anything with sea salt you got my vocal
tough guy with the sea salt and truffle
if i saw you aroused by sea salt and
truffle i'd offer you a fair one outside
that's great dude that's awesome you
know uh lewis is your co-host on uh on
believe you me and we had him on
uh one of the things that we asked him
was uh like the internet
listen yes he's garbage
i'm not even close there's no line of
questioning needed
but what i wanted well something that
that he came up with is one time he had
like an issue with like one of the
other kids dads at his kid's school and
i'm just curious
if you or your wife can answer has there
ever been a situation like that where
you kind of had to
straighten out another dad kind of in
public not physically but just kind of
let him know no i tend to kind of take
control of those
situations for more obvious reasons but
yeah
but to be honest no that hasn't really
yeah
no nothing nothing i remember one time
at flag football
[Laughter]
one of the kids does was kind of being a
[ __ ] you know so that was like whoa
here's my time
[Laughter]
all of a sudden i woke up do you know
what i mean started showing an interest
into what was actually happening but
uh but nothing happened but yeah no no
my dad when he was younger he was always
doing that he was always getting into
fights with
the other kids dads it was so [ __ ]
embarrassing
i remember my older brother my older
brother was in the school football team
and on the saturday morning i was there
just watching on the sidelines
and it was a cold morning and
my brother fouled someone i'm talking
soccer here
right of
that's a foul and he gives my brother a
yellow card right and my dad's shout out
oh referee or something you know he kind
of protests
and the referee shouted something back
at my dad right and then my dad
[ __ ] storms onto the football pit
in front of all the teamsters and
everybody and squares up to the referee
and then we can't hear what's going on
and then my dad just goes
boom oh [ __ ] headbutt
puts him flat on his back and walks over
he says
come on son let's get in the car oh my
god
i love the [ __ ] head but the straight
headbutt that's when you know it dad's a
loose cannon right there
that is yeah yeah so rebecca handles all
that kind of thing
ah it's smart and smart um another big
thing is
uh we do here is is when we can you know
we're wrapping up shortly yeah we're
getting close to wrapping it up here we
appreciate you guys
it is great and we love rebecca you
being on thanks yeah this is great
i want to follow up with rebecca rebecca
i want to follow up with something with
you we were asking michael
how do you feel about brushing your
teeth in the shower
you think that's trashy um
i don't think that's trashy i don't do
it but i don't i don't have a problem
with that because everyone
just kind of gets one um yeah
why did you did you expect me to think
otherwise is that like a
well kevin would i think that's an
acceptable thing michael said it was
acceptable
he started out saying it was trashy but
then he realized it isn't exciting no no
no no no no
yeah no no you could say it's a little
trashy but no
we're lucky we've got a big bathroom
right so i was like well hold on a
minute why would you walk over there
grab your
toothbrush i would get back i think i'm
like a rich guy
i'm like that's just weird but then i
thought you know imagine you're living
in a tiny little apartment
some people keep the toothbrush and
toothpaste in the shower if you keep it
in the shower that's disgusting that is
necessary i'm not saying that
if you keep it in there that's insane
people are washing their ass and [ __ ]
your toothbrush is there
[Laughter]
are you a straight uh you guys use
loofahs or you straight bar on skin
that's a big question she uses a loofah
for sure
of course i'm a woman i use a loofah um
michael how about you i'm a i it all
depends
you know what i'm saying like if it's
been a few days
uh since our last only 80 children said
that
i'll try and do a bit of that but if if
that was on let's say on the monday i
did that on the tuesday i'm bored on so
i'm boring
okay like a gentleman wednesday
something that annoys me what you do is
after you've used the loofah with the
soap he doesn't rinse it out and he just
kind
of leave it hanging there with all this
my girl says the same thing a little
gross
and disgusting yeah but i'll be honest i
know you're going to come in and pick it
up
[Laughter]
and what is the brand of soap in the
bisping house what do we use
um at the moment it's olay it's a
bottle of olay body wash um i mean we do
have bars of soap as well
like we're not opposed to a bar of soap
it's imperial leather
is it fancy stuff or is it like are you
is it
using dogs all right wow no irish spring
correct
no irish spring are you familiar with
irish spring
oh okay we consider that to be the
trashiest
of all soaps next to dial
also mike said you buy his hair product
and he said it's only three bucks
i said the other day they said oh you're
talking about some kind of
phone or something i said yeah and you
grabbed it from cvs and she said how
much i'm i don't know five bucks for
your hair
that that's stuff you know what it is i
don't
know um it's just normally the gels are
bumble and bumble
i don't even know what that is that
sounds that sounds
real sounds salon stuff that sounds like
a lot that sounds like a law firm bumble
and bumble
yeah it's like [ __ ] it does sound
like a law firm
that's ridiculous because it's like six
dollars or forty dollars a [ __ ] tub
on my wall going on so uh so yeah so i
started uh
getting cheap [ __ ] okay it looks
whatever it's a it's a home run
oh thank you thank you thank you that's
just me hitting on you mike
all right let's uh let's do you want to
do christmas real quick and then get out
of here yeah let's do christmas at the
bispings you guys celebrate christmas
oh massively okay all right this is
going to be good
all right so go ahead sorry do you do a
real real tree or a fake tree
um these days it has been a fake tree
i'm kind of tired of the
the mess of a real tree and everything
so i just do i just do fake treats
i insisted i know
i have to deal with it though it's me
that deals with it so yeah no because we
got dogs
as well and we've got kids yeah and i i
did on
a real tree for years but then they keep
banging into the dogs bang into it
the kids banging into where you know
there's like pine what do you call it
all the pine needles
yeah so anyway so no she bought a good
fake one i'll be honest you can't even
tell
okay ah i want to give it to you all
right it's tough though
let's do the deal breaker on this are
there are they colored lights on it or
are they all white lights
yeah all white lights ah i like their
facial reaction
that's a classy lady right there yes i
like that facial reaction right there
colored lights are yeah
garbage yeah rebecca's like she's a bit
of a weirdo when it comes to the
the lights she's very the lights the
christmas decorations everything like
she
just covers the tree like there's no
tinsel oh yeah
tinsel's trash is very trash
she's a classy lady when i grew up there
was tinsel on my trees that
kind of spiraled around it i'm like what
the [ __ ] tinsel said no
there's baubles only millions and
millions of baubles and lights and then
that's it yeah that's class that's very
elegant it's very
you know sophisticated very understated
she knows what she's doing yep yes she
does and what about on the house you do
white lights on the outside
white lights on the outside and no what
about like a plastic santa claus on the
on the lawn or anything like that you
don't [ __ ] with that do you
no no no no no we tried a couple of
things but
they're broken they're in there i see
here's the thing i'm the garbage one
we're getting that vibe you know so
we're like a weird hodgepodge like
certain parts of it is like super
classic then like what's going on over
here is that
that was my
you know what i mean to blow up santa
waving in the front yard or something
yeah they're all that little like
looking with those ornaments didn't we
like the jazz band you know
the black guys on the drums
ah michael's the trashy one rebecca is
the classy one i [ __ ] love it man
uh what else she got kid you got
anything else that's it for me ma'am
guys we appreciate it so much michael
thank you so much for staying with
rebecca it's great to meet you you guys
are [ __ ] absolutely fantastic
and class all the way up class all the
way that's the final judgment
and i'll tell you what you were on the
fence there for a little bit but that
little lady just put you over the
top you got a winner there my friend the
way she reacted
to colored lights was fan [ __ ] i
would like reaction best reaction you
could
she was she was physically disgusted she
was like huh
[ __ ] colored yeah yeah no i know no i
i'm very very lucky well listen fellas
it was a pleasure doing it i had a lot
of fun it was good
but i know it was a bit of a stressy
couple of minutes at the start of that
oh god
that was nothing i feel like this worked
out it was fun man it was fantastic dude
it was you know you know what we wanted
to ask we were talking about in the
beginning
uh how many all right of me
do you think you could fight given he's
probably about 350 right now 350
44. but yeah i told you about the
wrestling background and i also played
the cross in college
confidently in all of them i don't think
there's a number that you would stop at
20 it'd be a few
definitely be a few because like just
one punch
yeah you go that would scare away three
other ones i'm telling you right now
i wouldn't show up with less than 50 of
me
yeah yeah but like nobody wants to be
that first guy exactly
exactly i i've been in a lot of violent
situations over the years
situations where i've been surrounded by
like [ __ ] 20 people you know
but if you act and here's what i of my
older brother he was out we're in the
situation once and he got
surrounded by this gang all right bye
guys
thank you so much got surrounded by a
guy of uh gang of pakistanis near our
place
but
of course of course yeah oh [ __ ] we're
dead we're dead
we're dead and then my brother just
[ __ ] skits out with seconds yeah
come on [ __ ] let's go that's
good
you're just backed up because nobody
wants to be the first guy so anyway i
have
i've replicated that same technique on
many an occasion
i remember once i came out of a
nightclub in manchester and i'll leave
you on this
um this is fantastic
like 20 of them and they're all
surrounding me and i knew what was going
on they all started asking questions of
oh you're that cage fighter on you blah
blah blah
blah and i look around my [ __ ]
buddies had disappeared i'm by myself
and i'm like oh
[ __ ] um this is going to go bad they're
going to jump me
they're going to you know i'm going to
be in hospital pretty soon i'm going to
have a goal but they're all they'll look
like pretty big dudes as well
[ __ ] it here we go so i just said i said
um
have you ever seen that movie pulp
fiction and he says yeah
i said well do you know that scene where
he says i said i think they're
what are they doing i i think they're
cleaning out the blood in the car
i said you see that scene where they're
doing that and he says that i'm a race
car
and i'm in the red and it's dangerous to
have a race car in the red
and that this group lies they're all
like yeah yeah i remember that
i said well i'm just [ __ ] saying that
i'm a race car
and i'm in the [ __ ] red and it's
dangerous with a [ __ ] race car
in the red and they're all like oh yeah
yeah and then i walked off and i got
round the corner i was like oh my god
dude thank you so much michael bisping
thank you so much brother we'll see you
soon everybody make sure you check out
believe you me with louis gomez and mr
michael bisman buddy thank you so much
yeah ma'am
my pleasure you fellas all the best good
luck with the show keep up the good work
and uh
hopefully meet you in person soon
absolutely thank you brother
let's go baby and don't forget to get
your videos in for the are you garbage
garage fridge contest yes we're gonna
take the best five we're gonna have a
the next episode where it's just me and
kippy which is coming up pretty soon
we're going to be it's going to be next
week yeah the garage forget it
get it in now this will be your last
chance once you hear this to get it in
so get it in
and we already have some [ __ ]
phenomenal entries so we appreciate it
guys thank you so much uh what an
episode man we'll see you guys next week
peace peace